hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video we're
gonna go through your place guys we're
gonna analyze who is leading the ranking
on the trading games
and
christmas is coming so for december i
want to organize some special christmas
games where basically i'm going to
increase the price pool so for those who
are on discord just go and check it out
uh it's just i want to give back guys
some of the love that you're giving me
it's um i'm so grateful that you're here
supporting me on discord that you uh you
know without you this adventure could
not happen so i'm very very grateful for
that and i'm so happy to see that you
are learning things and that's the
purpose of those games is that you show
me the trades that you want to do you
give me the reasons why you do your
trades and we analyze it together so
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so we're gonna have a
look at the top three players alright so
we have amanda we have john lily and we
have skipper so they all have a few
plays so we're gonna go try to go
through all those plays for now we have
17 players for the month of november and
for december i hope we're going to have
more players but even if we don't like i
said guys i want to give back some of
the love you're giving me and whatever
the number of players i have already
posted uh in this code so you can have a
look at that
uh what is gonna happen for december so
let's start with amanda and her three
plays she's leading the ranking she is
not using leverage her best play is riot
all right so she bought riot on the 19th
of november
at 33 did she use a stop loss she had a
stop loss at 26.5
all right and she made 12 out of it so
let's have a look and the reason support
resistance trend line fib ratio retest
okay oh right so riot what do we have
so bam okay so this is riot on the daily
timeframe we indeed here have this trend
line that is showing us that we're
correcting and we had a breakout here
around 32 33
we pushed higher and then we corrected
and we came back to the breakout area
which is called a re-test and amanda
both on the retest at 33 very well done
so we did have the support this looks
like a first wave one two three four
five so let's see the fiber ratio of the
second wave 61.8 percent is at 32.5 so
it's indeed a fib ratio that is usual
for second waves so very well done
amanda this play makes a lot of sense
let's let's see if we're able to start
uh this third wave here it will depend a
lot on the bitcoin uh but i'm very
bullish on the bitcoin so it looks very
good we had already a position that we
built between here and here so that's
why we didn't increase our position here
but it's a very nice thread so
congratulations and well done
what is the next trade so b e k e is
only doing 1.5 percent i'm not gonna go
through this today i'm gonna focus on
mttr all right so here divergence rsi
and that's consideration before the move
so i checked that just before and indeed
here we have a trend line that has been
broken okay then we have this very
strong move up so amanda entered on the
18th of november so around here
uh so indeed here we have a strong move
up and before that we have here some
consolidation i would not call it a nice
consolidation amanda because for a
consideration to be nice we like to have
the bollinger bands that are tight and i
can already see they are not here okay
here they were tight so here we have a
nice consolidation okay
and then we had this
strong move up
that then got re-tested anyways and then
we pushed higher but
this is not a nice consolidation to me
maybe if i go on a fast time frame
okay on a fast time frame it's a nice
consolidation so fair enough it makes
sense and then we have the strong move
up so let's see if we're able to push
higher i would drew a trendline here and
basically if we are able to close above
30 we would probably push higher
especially that this is the all-time
high that we are hovering around for the
past week here in march all right we
were at 28 so it looks like we are
breaking out from this as well so this
is not done yet we can still be rejected
here but it's looking great because we
have this breakout with us we have the
momentum with us we are supported by the
20-day moving average that is coming
here you can see here one reaction one
reaction here here it was acting as
resistance so now it makes sense that
it's acting as support so yeah display
makes a lot of sense you didn't take any
profits or stop loss here yes
stop loss at 23 yeah
you can even put your stop loss slightly
above i mean at that time 23 makes sense
okay i would maybe use 24 right now i
would use the 20-day moving average as a
stop-loss so
24.33 i would be just below 24 and every
day i would increase that okay in order
to follow this 20-day moving average if
you want to have more room you can use
the 50. you can see we have one reaction
here and almost one direction here so i
prefer the 20 for those moves but the 50
is working too it just gives you
more room
so very well done amanda you are number
one you made 20 for now you did three
plays on the 10th 18th and 19th of
november so for now you are leading the
ranking so if you finish first you're
gonna of course get the reward that has
been announced on discord all right then
number two john lilly with a bearish
trade all right so johnny short
shorted review
okay on the 17th of november
just because of the volume but guys
volume is everything so that makes sense
let's have a look at that i think i've
checked this play already
before let's have a look at it again
generally very very nice so based on
volume so what did you see john okay
okay you see that we are pushing higher
but with a decreasing volume so this is
what we can call the volume divergence
it's more obvious on the daily time
frame i don't see it here very well
because here the volume looks stable but
i don't like to look the volume of the
daily on the forward it looks like it's
something is missing
so
okay you shorted review do you have any
target any stop loss target hundred and
thirty about you you are done already
okay i didn't see but look here the
target one so you reach your target and
this piano is closed actually
uh so you reached you you're we are
right now at 107 so you could have
pushed higher more like lower the price
could have pushed lower but very nice
trade very very well done so you locked
in 17
so amanda is still in uh exposed to the
market so maybe john is gonna be first
if uh we have some corrections on bek e
mttr all right so let's see what's gonna
happen and the last ones keeper brother
very well done i'm happy to see you here
uh so you are roughly flatish okay only
up 0.2
because you have three plays but
basically you have one play that costs
you a bit on bitcoin and you have a play
that uh helped you to make eight percent
so we're gonna go through this one and
it is interesting to see guys 17 players
and you can see that only the top three
is positive this month so it's just
showing you guys that this markets are
not easy all right making money is not
easy and the best one is making 20 which
is a very nice performance without using
leverage some of the players are using a
lot of leverage i can see times three
times five they are not on the rankings
i don't know if it's related or not but
i'm very happy to see
some
nice trades here and some players that
are able to generate nice profits so
skipper
let's analyze your play so cwh all right
nice consolidation before the move it's
been broken out a rectangle on the daily
okay
rectangle
triangle rectangle okay fair enough
let's let's check
and nice consideration before the move
and your boat at 42 okay
4th of november all right the very
beginning so you bought at 42 so i'm
gonna put here your buying order
bam 42
here very well done very well done so
once again
i don't see here yeah okay why not we
have some consideration here i would
personally use this breakout okay and
now i see the consideration better here
we can see that but then i don't like to
see that okay guys for breakout to be
perfect once again we want to see the
best indicators bollinger bands we want
to see them as tight as possible before
the breakout so here they were very
tight but then we moved down before
moving higher so it still got positive
results so it's good but i'm just
telling you what i am personally looking
for when i post my alerts i'm trying to
find something with very tight bollinger
bands here that shows that we have a lot
of energy in the market but here we are
the breakout we retested it we are
turning above the moving averages and we
just closed above the recent high so
this is looking great did you use a stop
loss brother of course stop plus 40 very
tight so buying 42 stop loss 40 i would
have used the stop loss slightly below
but
nice well done we traded at 40.20
okay so very well done a stop loss just
here i usually in this situation when i
buy the retest guys i try to find you
can switch the time frame try to find
where you have the moving averages
usually they are all in the same area
okay so here it's pretty obvious on the
daily time frame all the moving averages
were between 13 8 and 39 so i would have
personally used stop loss maybe
below the 20
around 38 to the 8.5 something like this
and i would have been buying a little
bit lower as well
so very well done congratulations so
this is it guys uh once again thank you
so much for playing we have only 17
players right now if we have two more
players for the month of november we're
gonna increase the price pool uh once
again uh come to this code if you are
not there two seats otherwise uh it's
the only place you can see it i don't
wanna disclose that uh here for now and
for christmas once again guys we're
gonna have
a bigger prize pool i hope that they're
gonna be a lot of you coming to play i
really enjoy checking what you are doing
and i just want to let you know guys
that i'm spending a lot of time right
now to try to create some trainings for
you uh some course but it takes a lot of
time it's not gonna be ready right away
but once it's gonna be ready we're gonna
be able to even better uh emphasize on
what is the the best setup to trade on
all the different rules that we need to
use to have a good risk management to
find the best place uh and to make uh
profits consistently but once again this
is not ready yet it's gonna come in
maybe one month i'm doing my best
working a lot and once again guys i'm so
grateful that you are here with me every
day on discord and i hope this adventure
will last even longer so thank you very
much and i see you when i'm back to
france see you guys